HE IS ALSO LIVE FROM GENEVA FOR
US THIS AFTERNOON.
HI, RICH.
>> HEY, SANDRA, JUST AROUND THE
CORNER FROM JOHN HERE.
IT STARTED ON THE TRIP EARLIER
THIS WEEK WITH THE G7 STATEMENT
TO THE EFFECT PUSHING ON THE
W.H.O. IN COVID-19, WE HAVE JUST
GOTTEN A STATEMENT FROM THE
UNITED STATES AND EUROPEAN UNION
THAT HAD SOME CONSULTATIONS IN
BRUSSELS SAYING THAT WE CALL FOR
PROGRESS ON A TRANSPARENT
EVIDENCE-BASED AN EXPERT LEAD
W.H.O. CONVENED A PHASE 2 STUDY
ON THE ORIGINS OF COVID-19 THAT
IS FREE FROM INTERFERENCE AND WE
COMMIT TO WORKING TOGETHER FOR
DEVELOPMENT IN USE OF A SWIFT
AND INDEPENDENT MEANS FOR
INVESTIGATING SUCH OUTBREAKS IN
THE FUTURE.
CHINA’S GOVERNMENT REFUSES THAT
AN INDEPENDENT EXAMINATION INTO
THE ORIGINS OF THE VIRUS IN
CHINA TO DETERMINE WHETHER THIS
CAME FROM NATURE OR THE WUHAN
INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY.
WITH THAT REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS ARE
CALLING FOR ANOTHER DOMESTIC
INQUIRY.
>> DEFINITELY NOT USING THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION TO
INVESTIGATE, WHY DON’T YOU USE
CHINA TO INVESTIGATE AS WELL.
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR WHAT
THEY HAD DONE AND THE DEPTH THEY
HAVE CAUSED AROUND THE WORLD.
>> SECRETARY OF STATE ANTONY
BLINKEN ON THIS TRIP WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN CALLED THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION’S FIRST
INVESTIGATION HIGHLY DEFICIENT
AND THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR CHINA.
IT IS UNCLEAR WHAT EXACTLY THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY WILL BE AND IF
THE UNITED STATES AND JOE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DETERMINE AD TO
OTHER AMERICAN ALLIES WILL JOIN
THE U.S. IN THAT ACCOUNTABILITY.
FOR NOW OFFICIALS ARE POINTING
TO THAT INDEPENDENT REVIEW THAT
THE U.S. INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
IS LOOKING INTO TO LOOK INTO
WHETHER THIS WAS A LAB LEAK OR
CAME FROM NATURE DUE BY THE END
OF AUGUST.
>> Sandra: GOOD STUFF FROM
THERE, CHANGE OF SCENERY FOR YOU
AS WELL, RICH EDSON.
>> John: HE IS EXPERIENCING
THE SAME BEAUTIFUL SCENE THAT WE
ARE.
THERE’S ANOTHER SCENE ON
CAPITOL HILL THAT RAND PAUL IN
THE GREAT STATE OF KENTUCKY, SO
SENATOR PAUL THE W.H.O. BEING
INSTRUCTED BY THE G7 WHICH WILL
POINT OUT THAT THE W.H.O. IS
HERE IN GENEVA TO TAKE A SECOND
REVIEW AT THE ORIGINS OF
COVID-19 WHETHER IT CAME OUT OF
THE LABORATORY.
DIDN’T EINSTEIN ONCE SAY THE
DEFINITION OF INSANITY IS DOING
THE SAME THING OVER AND OVER
AGAIN?
EXPECTING A DIFFERENT RESULT?
>> HERE IS A PROBLEM, THE W.H.O.
INVESTIGATED THIS THE FIRST TIME
AND WE SUGGESTED THREE PEOPLE TO
SEND TO CHINA, THEY REJECTED ALL
THREE.
AND ACCEPTED A GUY NAMED PETER
DAY ZACH WHO WAS THE ONE WHO
FUNDED THE LAB, SO YOU CAN OF
ANTHONY FAUCI OR PETER DAY ZACH
WHO WERE PART OF THE FUNDING
MECHANISM TO SEND THESE FUNDS TO
WUHAN LABS, YOU CAN’T HAVE THEM
INVESTIGATING THEMSELVES, THEY
HAVE A DEFINITE CONFLICT OF
INTEREST BECAUSE IF THIS
PANDEMIC STARTED IN A LAB THAT
THE U.S. WAS FUNDING, THE PEOPLE
ADVOCATING FOR THE FUNDING
OBVIOUSLY WILL HAVE CULPABILITY,
AT LEAST MORAL CULPABILITY, THEY
CAN INVESTIGATE THEMSELVES IN
THE W.H.O. DID A TERRIBLE JOB
THE FIRST TIME.
THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
INVESTIGATION, BUT I WOULD
ADVOCATE FOR A CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATION IN THE SENATE.
I’VE ASKED TWO COMMITTEES THAT I
AM ON, THE HEALTH LABOR IMPINGES
COMMITTEE TO INVESTIGATE THIS.
I HAVE NOT HEARD FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC CHAIRMAN SO FAR, BUT
I THINK THAT THIS SHOULD BE
INVESTIGATED.
I DON’T THINK THAT IT HAS TO BE
PARTISAN, WE SHOULD ALL WANT TO
KNOW HOW THE PANDEMIC STARTED
AND ALL WANT TO KNOW SO WE DON’T
HAVE THIS HAPPEN AGAIN WITH
ANOTHER LAB LEAK OF A MORE
DANGEROUS VIRUS.
>> John: THE COMMUNICATION
THAT CAME OUT OF THE SUMMIT IN
CORNWALL, ENGLAND, TALKED ABOUT
THEM WANTING TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF CORONAVIRUS AND
SOMETHING TO SAY ABOUT THE HUMAN
RIGHTS ABUSES, THEY TOOK A PAGE
OUT OF VLADIMIR PUTIN’S PLAYBOOK
AND SAID WHO CARES WHAT A
HANDFUL OF NATIONS SAY, WE ARE
LOOKING TOWARDS THE G20 SUMMIT.
AND DOES THE G7 HAVE THE HAPS TO
PUT THE SCREWS TO CHINA?
PARTICULARLY WITH COUNTRIES LIKE
GERMANY REALLY GETTING INTO
BIGGER ECONOMIC DEALS WITH CHINA
WHERE FRANCE IS BEING INVESTED
INTO A MUCH GREATER DEGREE.
DO THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO PUT
THE SCREWS TO CHINA?
>> I THINK IT’S VERY DIFFICULT
FOR ANY INTERNATIONAL BODY TO
MAKE ANOTHER COUNTRY THAT DOES
NOT WANT TO LISTEN SAY, HEY, DO
YOU THINK THAT THE ENTIRE WORLD
WAS AFFECTED BY THE PANDEMIC
OVER 3.5 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE
DIED, THE TYPE OF RESOURCES THEY
WERE DOING IN CHINA HAS EVEN
DEADLIER IMPLICATIONS, ONE OF
THE VIRUSES THEY HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON HAS A 15 TIMES MORE
GREATER 15 PEOPLE DEAD, SO THE
WHOLE WORLD HAS A SELF-INTEREST
IN MAKING SURE THAT CHINA
BEHAVES, BUT THE ONLY WAY WE
WILL GET THEM TO BEHAVE IS WITH
ALL SOURCES BY THE WHOLE WORLD
AND I AGREE WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WE SHOULD HAVE
GOTTEN OUT OF THE W.H.O. AND SAY
WE ONLY GET BACK AND COMING ONLY
GET ANY OF OUR MONEY IF THERE IS
A REAL HONEST TO GOODNESS
INVESTIGATION OF VIRUS CAME FROM
FROM.
>> John: LET ME TO GET YOU TO
WEIGH IN ON TOMORROW’S CEMENT IF
I COULD, WHEN HE WAS LEAVING
NATO, PRESIDENT BIDEN SUGGESTING
DIALING BACK THE CRITICISMS,
ALSO WITH A PREVIEW OF THE
SUMMIT SAYING HE IS NOT LOOKING
FOR A CONFLICT WITH RUSSIA,
LISTEN HERE AND I WILL GET YOU
TO REACT ON THE OTHER SIDE.
>> I’M NOT LOOKING FOR CONFLICT
WITH RUSSIA.
BUT THAT WE WILL RESPOND IF
RUSSIA CONTINUES THEIR HARMFUL
ACTIVITIES.
AND WE WILL NOT FAIL TO DEFEND
THE TRANS ATLANTIC ALLIANCE OR
STAND UP FOR DEMOCRATIC VALUES.
>> John: IS DIALING BACK THE
BEST WAY TO DEAL WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN NOR SHOULD HE GO
INTO THAT MEETING WITH HIS
GLOVES OFF?
>> I THINK THAT WE ARE
APPROACHING A TIME PERIOD THAT
IS NOT TO JUST SIMILAR TO THE
COLD WAR, AND THE COLD WAR
RUSSIA, THE SOVIET UNION HAD ALL
KINDS OF HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES
THAT WE OBJECTED TO IT AND SPOKE
OUT AGAINST IT, AND
RONALD REAGAN DID TALK ABOUT
NUCLEAR ARMS CONTROL, WE HAVE
THE SAME SITUATION NOW, THERE IS
A GREAT DEAL OF EVIDENCE AND A
POISONING OF THE OPPONENTS OF
PEOPLE BEING POISONED AROUND THE
WORLD OF A RUSSIAN NERVE AGENT
WHICH SEEMS TO HAVE COME FROM
RUSSIA, SO WE HAVE ALL OF THESE
THINGS AND THEY NEED TO BE
CONDEMNED, AT THE SINGLE TIME WE
NEED TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
RUSSIA AND CHINA OVER NUCLEAR
ARMS CONTROL AND MAKE SURE THAT
THE WORLD IS ASSURED THAT WE ARE
NOT A BELIEVER IN THE FIRST
STRIKE AND WE WANT TO REDUCE
NUCLEAR ARMS, THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT NO MATTER HOW BAD THE
HUMAN RIGHTS ARE FOR SOME
DIALOGUE.
>> John: GIVE ME JUST A COUPLE
OF SECONDS FOR THIS, BUT SHOULD
THERE BE A JOINT PRESS
CONFERENCE TOMORROW BETWEEN THE
TWO LEADERS?
SHOULD PRESIDENT BIDEN GET UP ON
STAGE WITH PUTIN AND TALK
PUBLICLY?
>> I THINK THAT OBJECTS ARE
IMPORTANT AND I DON’T KNOW IF I
HAVE THE BEST ADVICE ON WHETHER
THEY SHOULD BE JOINT OR
SEPARATE, BUT THERE ARE WAYS TO
MAKE OUR CASE KNOWN TO CONDEMN
HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES BUT AT THE
SAME TIME STILL BE WILLING TO
HAVE A DIALOGUE WITH RUSSIA AND
CHINA.
IT IS A DIFFICULT AND DELICATE
DANCE DIPLOMACY, BUT WE CANNOT
TO CUT OURSELVES OFF OR REFUSE
TO HAVE DIALOGUE.
WE STILL NEED TO HAVE OPEN
DIALOGUE WITH CHINA AND RUSSIA.